vous êtes venu témoigner de la torture
vous avez subi de 6 à 9 ans avec votre
petite sœur qui n'avait elle n'avait que
deux ans de moins que vous vous êtes
passé à la DASS puis après on vous plait
chez un couple Monique et François qui
devient votre famille d'accueil ce que
vous racontez quels sont vos premières
impressions quand vous arrivez ce que
déjà on est on est complètement perdu
puisqu'on nous sépare de notre cocon
familial de notre mère de notre famille
pourquoi vous enlevé de votre famille on
a été victime d'un signalement on a été
placé parce que nous étions injurieuse à
l'école maternelle et qui nous arrivait
parfois de louper en fait la classe
savoir qu'à l'époque ce n'était pas
obligatoire
donc voilà ça a conduit à ce placement
on avait de quoi manger on avait une
famille aimante et vous êtes vous êtes
fait placer donc on vous sort de chez
vos parents alors que contre votre gris
contre le gris de vos parents et on vous
place dans une famille
c'est déjà ça déjà c'est en cours ça
démarre déjà c'est n'importe quoi c'est
encore à chaque fois dans cette émission
on marche sur la tête parce que dès
qu'on arrive on voit que rien ne va
c'est n'importe quoi vos premières
impressions donc sur le sur le couple
qui vous accueille on est arrivé on est
rentré dans cette cette grande maison
c'était une très belle maison le couple
parfait avec deux enfants
un chien
on est quand même perturbé parce qu'on
perd toutes nos repères en permanence on
perd notre famille on se retrouve moi
j'avais 6 ans donc j'étais j'étais une
gamine ma petite sœur 4 ans on se
retrouve à rentrer dans une maison
immense on est en train de pleurer et
tellement on pleure on s'endort on
s'endort dans la chambre de la fille de
la famille d'accueil et on se réveille
la nuit et quand on se réveille on se
rend compte que c'est bien la réalité
qu'on ait pu avec notre famille on sait
pas où on est on sait pas ce qui se
passe
c'est incroyable donc vous êtes avec
votre petite sœur qui a deux ans de
moins que vous
faites très vite faut devenir témoins de
scènes de torture de viol sur d'autres
enfants qu'est-ce qui se passe qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé
peut-on après notre arrivée j'entends
des hurlements d'un bébé
il y avait deux enfants de quel âge
et en fait j'ai traversé tout le couloir
toute la course de la maison j'ai monté
les escaliers je vais arriver dans la
chambre et elle était en train
d'enfoncer
un bateau dans les fesses du bébé
donc voilà ma petite sœur est arrivée
directement
et quand
j'ai voulu intervenir je lui ai mis des
coups de pieds j'ai craché sur elle pour
qu'elle achète le bébé
donc j'ai essayé de faire ce que je
pouvais et là elle m'a attrapé elle
m'emmener dans la salle de bain et
maintenant elle est dans l'eau froide
j'ai commencé à appeler ma petite sœur
elle m'a dit tu veux ta soeur elle est
partie la chercher elle a ramené ma
soeur elle a commencé à noyer ma sœur à
côté de moi
il a fallu attendre de longues minutes
avant qu'elle nous lâche j'ai cru qu'on
allait mourir et nous a relâché pile
poil au moment où on suffoqué tellement
que
voilà
commence ce jour-là vous voulez vous
interpreposer et puisque vous êtes
témoin de cette scène tragique et pareil
que vous arrivez dans une pièce remplie
d'excréments ou un enfant et donc
l'enfant hurlé c'est là que vous voyez
ça mais il a été rempli d'excrément la
pièce oui
son frère me disait tata mon bébé mon
bébé pour que j'essaie de sauver le bébé
mais en fait j'étais avec un enfant
alors ensuite donc
comment ça se passe au quotidien parce
que là c'est le début
donc là là c'est la
votre maman de votre famille d'accueil
est-ce que le papa était là est-ce qu'il
est au courant bien sûr il était à côté
d'elle d'accord au moment où et lui il
avait aucune réaction il était une
réaction aucune réaction il était y
participait il participait avec sa femme
alors ce cauchemar démarre
qu'est-ce que vous dites la première
nuit vous savez que là vous êtes dans
une famille
que vous n'avez pas choisi vous allez
quitter votre famille alors que vous lui
restez avec elle et vous vous retrouvez
avec des gens qui font subir des
sucettes et sévices à des enfants vous
dites quoi prenez soin qu'est-ce que
vous dites à votre petite sœur
on arrive même plus à parler on se
retrouve on est on est choqué parce
qu'on n'avait jamais pris de poux nous
on savait pas ce que c'était de se faire
taper on savait pas ce que c'était de se
faire noyer on savait quand j'ai vu la
scène avec le bébé moi pour moi j'avais
jamais vu ça
on se retrouve dans la dans la pièce on
bouge plus
on nous a laissé nu avec une serviette
que nous avait balancé
et ensuite là le cauchemar va devenir
quotidien
qu'est-ce qui se passe au quotidien au
quotidien c'était les réveils très tôt
le matin
vers 6h du matin il arrivait aussi qu'il
fasse nuit
était plus voilà il était
plus suiveur en fait il était suiveur
mais il a participé à des choses dont je
vais pas parler ce soir voilà donc le
matin on emmené ma sœur dans les
toilettes pour l'étouffer avec un
entonnoir
et mettez de la nourriture dans
l'entonnoir
moi j'attendais derrière la porte que ça
se termine donc ma soeur elle venait la
mort et elle lui mettait dans
l'entonnoir la nourriture c'était des
petits pois du riz du poisson et ma
soeur elle sait tout fait et je pouvais
rien faire j'attendais
il fallait que ma sœur à balle sinon on
partait pas à l'école ils ont obligé à
manger de la cervelle d'agneau cru oui
c'était les repas elle nous oblige à
manger de la cervelle d'agneau au cru
qu'elle allait chercher régulièrement au
supermarché
elle nous disait ça c'est ton cerveau il
faut que tu le manges
qu'est-ce qui vous disait quand vous
quand vous protestiez vos bourreaux donc
vous pouvez pas protester de toute façon
les seules fois on a essayé de protester
c'est d'essayer d'attraper les mains on
pouvait pas c'était pas possible
six ans et 4 ans c'est impossible de
protester de dire quoi que ce soit on
les supplie on se mettait à genoux au
sol pour qu'ils arrêtent
vous avez fini par accepter ce quotidien
de torture bien sûr
il vous faisait croire que c'était
mérité ils vous disait quoi c'était
normal en fait nous on pensait qu'on
avait fait des bêtises donc on disait
qu'à la fin
c'était ça
mais eux vous êtes dépouilleuse vous
êtes des enfants de Lada sans vous
croire à jamais
vous pouvez rien dire
par les autres enfants il y a eu ça mais
les autres scènes on les a pas tout vu
mais toutes les autres scènes de torture
c'était souvent sur ma sœur
et c'est
difficile en fait quand on force votre
sœur à manger un plat de pâtes énorme on
lui dit il faut que tu le finisses tu
vas le finir quand on l'attrape par les
cheveux qu'on la met dans la cave il y a
d'autres d'autres choses comme ça c'est
c'est compliqué
on s'est réveillé plusieurs fois la nuit
dans un endroit
dont on se souvenait pas d'avoir été
emmené
et vous vous retrouvez dans une pièce
dans le noir ou vous êtes bloqué au
milieu de la pièce il y a votre sœur qui
pousse à toi au milieu de la pièce il y
a pas de plainte il y a pas de fenêtre
donc je disais à ma sœur reste là bouge
pas puis je vais je vais toucher au sol
contre le mur voir s'il y a une porte il
y a pas de porte il y a pas de fenêtre
il y a rien tu finis par revenir au
milieu de la pièce dans le noir et tu
attends donc on s'est évanoui plus rien
c'était combien d'enfants placés chez ce
couple on était
1 2 3 on était quatre quatre enfants
placés chez un couple ils enlèvent les
enfants chez leurs parents contre leur
gris parce qu'il y a une plainte parce
qu'ils allaient pas à l'école je sais
plus quoi ils étaient ils avaient un
mauvais comportement à l'école ils se
retrouvent dans une famille qui fait
subir ça est-ce que vous vous rendez
compte de cette ineptie une fois de plus
on voit que ça tourne à l'envers ça sent
dans le pays ça tourne à l'envers
est-ce que vous avez essayé d'en parler
à un adulte oui bien sûr à qui j'allais
voir la psychologue de l'organisme de
placement
que j'avais vu je lui dis ce qu'on ce
que j'ai vu sur la petite
je veux dire ce que nous faisait quoi
que nous faisait dormir dans la cave
qu'on était qu'on mourait de faim
sauf qu'elle me dénonçait j'ai prévenu
l'éducatrice il y avait le direct ils
ont parlé aux parents derrière enfin
tu as parlé l'inata parlé et ben au
moment de rentrer c'était la nuit dans
la cave et là tu sais que tu parles une
fois deux fois tu peux plus parler parce
que c'est pas possible dans une
interview vous dites que vos bourreau
était malin parce que les sévices que
vous subissiez ne laissez pas de trace
bien sûr on peut pas on peut pas
remarquer que personne n'a rien remarqué
à l'école non il y a l'école vous en
avez pas parlé même vos copines j'ai
fait une grosse crise d'angoisse un jour
à l'école
ce qui a mené d'ailleurs au fait que
elle nous sorte de cette école parce
qu'elle avait peur que je parle
donc voilà j'en pouvais plus des nuits
dans la cave et des bestioles qu'elle me
mettait dans mes vêtements
donc le truc c'est que quand je suis
arrivé à l'école bah j'ai craqué j'ai
couru je me suis entièrement dans les
toilettes je voulais voir ma sœur
j'avais besoin de me rassurer avec ma
sœur j'en pouvais plus
et là nous a changé d'école parce
qu'elle sentait que j'allais parler dans
l'école
au bout de trois ans de censé enfer vous
retournez chez votre mère commence
comment vous avez pu retourner chez
votre mère envoyez ma mère le mercredi
d'accord
on pouvait pas en parler à ma mère parce
qu'elle nous disait qu'elle allait tuer
ma mère qu'elle allait lui faire du mal
et qu'on
reviendrait chez elle prendre rentrera
jamais chez notre mère donc il fallait
surtout qu'on ne parle pas on avait
tellement peur de cette femme qu'il
fallait rien dire en fait
et donc vous retournez chez votre mère
là vous découvrez une vie normale
et derrière vous lui en parler à un
moment ou pas du tout
à votre mère vous lui avez parlé à quel
moment non ma mère elle a pris elle a
tout appris l'année dernière sur sur les
réseaux parce qu'on voulait la préserver
vous voulez pas lui faire de mal et puis
on avait honte de raconter notre
histoire en fait ça fait des années
qu'on se bat pour pouvoir obtenir
justice et vous pouvez pas dire à votre
mère tout ce que vous avez subi parce
que on va la faire culpabiliser
incroyable les années plus tard vous
voyez votre sœur vous apprenez par la
police que l'un des enfants avec qui
vous viviez en famille d'accueil qui
avait un an à l'époque avait été violé
au point d'en devenir autiste
oui on a laissé le petit bébé Arnaud il
avait 11 mois et à ce moment-là que vous
décidez d'en parler de rendre cette
affaire
donc là il nous demande comment ça s'est
passé là-bas et puis il nous parle
rapidement d'Arnaud en nous disant qu'il
est pas bien
et c'est à ce moment là bah moi que je
me suis effondré ma sœur elle était dans
une autre dans une autre pièce avec
d'autres gendarmes et là je répète en
fait
tout ce qui s'est passé pour nous tous
et en fait Arnaud lui il a été violé il
lui en fait des choses encore plus grave
que ce qu'on a vécu nous
donc voilà
alors finalement de ces trois années
vous et votre sœur vous gardez les
séquelles bien sûr je vous appelle je
vous empêche encore aujourd'hui de vivre
une vie normale on va parvenir sur
l'aspect judiciaire dans un instant avec
travocats pour avec Maître Anne-Claire
le jeune pour savoir où ça en est mais
vous vous avez des séquelles bien sûr à
vie quels sont ces séquelles on est
claustro on a du mal à dormir
correctement la nuit on a peur du noir
on est obligé de dormir avec la télé ou
une lumière il est impossible pour vous
de manger autre chose que des liquides
alors ma petite sœur là ma sœur elle ne
peut toujours pas manger elle est obligé
de s'alimenter que de liquide
quand on vous met entonnoir dans la
gorge je vous laisse imaginer le truc on
vous le on vous massacre en fait donc
elle elle peut manger que liquide
normalement
moi j'arrive à manger des trucs tout
bête quoi je vais ça peut paraître bête
mais j'arrive à manger des coquillettes
j'arrive à manger du blanc de poulet des
choses comme ça que j'aurais jamais pu
manger avant moi ce qui nous rend fou
c'est qui on l'a vu dans le reportage de
l'interdits vous avez été à la rencontre
de ce couple qui vit une vie une petite
vie tranquille j'ai je vous dis le temps
des jours et des jours que je fais cette
émission et à chaque fois je me dis on
est dans un monde incroyable on est dans
un monde qui ne tourne pas rond on est
dans un pays où tout marche à l'envers
donc eux ils sont tranquilles chez eux
une vive une vie normale paisible
totalement comment ça se fait ça maître
non mais ce dossier est absolument
hallucinant et malheureusement c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui on entend ce
témoignage mais elle se fait l'écho de
aussi beaucoup d'autres victimes qui ont
pas forcément la force de parler comment
se fait-il que ces gens sont en liberté
tranquille chez eux pourquoi sont-ils en
liberté alors dans le cas présent je
pense qu'il y a eu très clairement des
dysfonctionnements du côté de la
protection de l'enfance c'est ce que
disait le reportage hier là on a un
exemple concret il y avait un jugement
puisque apparemment apparemment là il y
a eu des témoignages puisque la police
la gendarmerie a été
2002 Lina et sa soeur sont entendus en
qualité de moi
s'agissant de la procédure qui porte en
fait sur l'effet dénoncé par leur petit
frère exactement voilà c'est ça
ce qui est assez surprenant d'ailleurs
c'est que le procureur juge pas utile
d'élargir les poursuites au fait que ils
ont le témoignage des deux des deux
filles et bah pour autant derrière il y
a le il y a le petit il y a l'affaire du
petit donc il les entendent en tant que
témoin écouter ça chez vous parce que il
est 21h11 on marche sur la tête encore
une fois derrière elles font un
témoignage accablons et dans lesquels
dans lequel elle raconte leur série si
elle rencontre tout ce qu'elles ont vécu
et derrière ils ouvrent pas d'enquête il
reste sur le petit Arnaud il dit on va
voir déjà au lieu mais moi je vous dis
quand on entend ça je vous dis
franchement on peut plus croire en rien
ici on se dit je suis désolé
là une fois de plus c'est un truc on se
dit moi je suis le père biologique des
deux petites filles je vous dis ça se
termine très mal
parce qu'aujourd'hui on se dit bah si
c’est devenu n'importe quoi aujourd'hui
la justice comment la justice a pu
passer à côté d'un tel cas et comment
comment ces gens sont encore en liberté
il m'a dit qu'il continue pas non mais
non mais même non mais oui bah ça c'est
sûr et pourquoi ils sont encore en
liberté alors moi je peux pas y répondre
c'est certain c'est que Lina a dans
l'intention de par la suite faire aussi
une procédure pour fonte lourdes contre
l'État il y aura certainement des
responsabilités à identifier ça c'est
évident depuis le début il y en a il y
en a au niveau elle vous dit j'ai
dénoncé l'effet à l'éducatrice j'ai
dénoncé dénoncé les faits à la
psychologue pour autant rien à bouger
rien du tout et après quand enfin elles
sont entendues en tant que témoin et
bien le procureur ne fait pas de
réquisitoire supplétif et effectivement
c'est fait pour lesquels elles sont
victimes ne sont pas inclus dans la
procédure donc il faut attendre
finalement 2019 pour que Lina et sa
soeur décide de déposer une plainte au
commissariat une plainte gérée formelle
durant ces trois années donc de 2019 à
ce jour il ne se passe rien du tout et
là il y a eu plein de déposés auprès du
jus d'instruction pour qu'on puisse
enfin avancer la famille d'accueil elle
a eu l'agrément pendant combien d'années
alors déjà on sait même pas si
véritablement un anagramment
on nous a dit qu'elle aurait été
licenciée j'aimais les intérêts à ce
sujet là
voilà quand on n'a pas de pas
d'informations par contre je sais
qu'elle a essayé de se faire embaucher
dans d'autres départements a priori elle
a continué à exercer pendant pas mal de
temps voilà jusqu'à leur aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui eux ils ont quel âge 66 66
ans et 71 ans je suis bien au courant
elle a la même date de naissance que moi
cette femme d'accord à jamais l'oublier
pour mon anniversaire
et aujourd'hui donc ils vivent
paisiblement chez eux ils sont
tranquilles
vous de voir ces gens qui continuent à
vivre normalement ça vous fait quoi
à vivre comme ça en toute impunité notre
petit frère de placement il est dans un
centre spécialisé pour les enfants en
difficulté
il a de très faible moyen il a une vie
qui est complètement gâchée il aura
peut-être jamais d'enfants j'ai ma sœur
qui peut pas travailler ils nous
engagent chez nos vies voilà j'ai de la
chance d'avoir une activité
professionnelle mais quand ça va pas je
me retrouve en arrêt maladie parce que
mon corps il suit pas
voilà donc c'est honteux
leurs enfants vivent une vie normale
leurs petits-enfants c'est pareil
leurs enfants non
ils nous ont jamais porté secours et
nous voyaient nous faire massacrer nous
faire enfermer dans la cave j'amène nous
ont proposé nous donner ne serait-ce
qu'un petit truc à manger on ramasser
les miettes dans la voiture pour pouvoir
manger des miettes de gâteaux
vous avez vu aussi Lola 12 ans a été
assassiné d'une manière atroce à Paris
vendredi 23h découvre une mal renfermant
le corps sans vie de Lola et prévient
les secours on pense bien sûr très fort
à sa famille ce soir